con el apodo de supermario se esperaba
que mario draghi pudiera ser el que
sacara italia de una serie de crisis fue
en febrero del año pasado cuando este
hombre de 74 años aceptó formar un nuevo
gobierno reconociendo importantes retos
el momento difícil
es un momento difícil el presidente ha
hablado de la dramática crisis sanitaria
y de sus graves efectos en la vida de
las personas en la economía en la
sociedad la gravedad de la emergencia
exige respuestas que estén a la altura
la conciencia de la emergencia
ricky de disparos de la artista de la
situación
draghi asumió el cargo de primer
ministro después de que el último
gobierno de italia presidido por
giuseppe conte se hundiera en enero tras
perder la mayoría en el senado draghi
pasó días reuniendo un gobierno de
unidad nacional y contaba con una amplia
gama de partidos desde el movimiento
antisistema cinco estrellas hasta la
liga de extrema derecha una de las
razones por las que tantos de ellos
unieron fuerzas es que todos querían
tener voz y voto en la forma en la que
italia gastaba los más de doscientos mil
millones de euros de los fondos de
recuperación de la unión europea mario
draghi es una figura muy conocida en las
finanzas italianas de 1984 a 1990 fue
director ejecutivo del banco mundial y
después pasó por goldman sachs y el
banco de italia en 2011 fue nombrado
presidente del banco central europeo
cargo que ocupó hasta 2019 en este
puesto se le atribuye el mérito de haber
sacado al euro del borde del colapso
durante la crisis de la deuda soberana
haciendo su ya famosa promesa de hacer
lo que sea necesario